interval notation is something which
we're thinking about in the context of
mainly for us domain and range okay so
this is kind of attached to domain and
range for our intents and purposes it's
essentially another way to talk about
domain and range another way to express
it the only way we know at the moment is
with inequalities right so with
inequalities we're going to show you
know how do you write something normally
what does that look like and then I'm
going to show you the interval notation
equivalent of that so maybe if you want
to draw like three columns here the
first thing we're going to say is
something familiar and inequality I'm
gonna ask us to draw what that looks
like so you might even remember back to
year 7 and we sort of repres eyes decide
this year sometimes we'd ask you to draw
a number line and show where the
inequality sits on that number line and
then the last thing we're going to
finish with is what's the equivalent in
interval notation so these are our three
little headings you okay so let's start
with an easy one if I asked you to write
for me
what's the inequality that corresponds
to I don't know between 1 and 3 and you
include your boundaries how would you
write that won't be the first thing that
I write I want to be between 1 & 3 and
I'm including the boundaries what's the
first thing I'm gonna write your asset I
can't I'm gonna write that okay so I'm
between 1 & 3 so this tells me from what
I'm gonna go that way okay and then I've
got to stop somewhere right where am I
gonna stop at 3 so how am I gonna write
that part X is less than or equal to 3
now I've got a pair inequalities here
and I actually need them to kind of fit
together I need to relate them in some
way I'm going to use a word a single
word but I'm gonna let you choose right
what word would be appropriate to join
these together if what I want is between
1 & 3
any suggestions
now you be clear I'll give you twice
--is it's one of these words or or and
what do you reckon hmm this is
interesting isn't it one of the things
about maths right one of the things that
makes it hard to learn but also powerful
is that just in a few letters right
there's a lot of difference between
these two words
right ah very good
hold on you say that again sorry but
louder ever I can hear you okay so one
of these means you sort of can choose
you can choose which one you'd like and
the other one means no no no you can't
choose you need to hold on to both of
them at the same time so I'm gonna ask
you this question again if I want to be
between one and three do I get to pick
and choose between the two them or do I
have to include and hold on to both at
the same time yeah I need them both
don't I yeah good so I'm gonna say and
right if I had said all right if I said
all let's think of a number like say
zero right if I said or does zero
qualify does it agree with this right is
X greater than or equal to one well 0 is
not greater than or equal to 1 but 0 is
less than or equal to 3 thumbs up so if
you said all right if I asked you to buy
me a pizza and I said it can be either
cheese or pepperoni and you got me just
one of them I would be happy right but
if I asked you to have and I need both
of them at the same time I mean what
kind of repeats would be of had no
cheese anyway so I've got an including
both right that's fine there is actually
another more Steven more succinct way to
say exactly the same thing with
inequalities so anyone oh yeah I can
write it in a single line I'm between 1
& 3 right so I can say ones less than or
equal to X which is less than or equal
to 3
these both mean exactly the same thing
okay so which one do you prefer to be
honest I I'd be happy with Oh both of
them have literally the same meaning if
this makes all sense to you say it
absolutely saying
I kind of tend to ride this one only
because I'm lazy and it's shorter but
here's a more important fact you kind of
need to be able to read both of them you
need to be able to see either of them
and know that they mean the same thing
is that okay can we draw this real quick
yep correct that's exactly right
so just in Christian catch what's around
you said see this part here it's kind of
like don't move hand it's kind of like
this guy here but it's in reverse order
do you see that and because inequalities
pay attention to order which ones on the
left and which ones on the right as
opposed to equations like this this will
do two plus three equals five five also
equals to two plus three right so you
can switch that order around no problem
because that's what an equation means
they're equal but these are inequalities
they literally mean they are not equal
so you can't treat both sides the same
okay can we draw this guy right it's
between 1 & 3 so I'm gonna check 1 & 3
on my number line I also tend to like
zero because I think that's a really
important whoops number climb making
sure it's nice what am I going to put
onto the number line now that I've got
my numbers there what kinds of circles
do I need well that's just this hold on
let's hold on rest now I'm going to see
if anyone else has got this hmm
so so because I'm including the
boundaries say loud option
very good so I'm going to close these
circles up because the boundaries are
included like so and then I draw the
line in between and obviously you know
it'll be very common in fact in exams we
encourage you to just write with one
color so this line in between I just
make it super ultra fat so I can really
clearly see it okay over the top there I
don't encourage you to write it above or
below this is clearer wrastlin you have
a question okay so some people some
people will write their or draw their
line up above I encourage you not to
because at the moment this is what we
call a one-dimensional inequality right
what's a dimension it's a direction
along which you can move right we leave
in three dimensions because you can go
or go left and right we can go up and
down and then we could also go forward
backward right now this is only one
dimension it's only left and right when
you've got only one dimension to deal
with up and down doesn't mean anything
right so put it up here put up there no
big deal but guess what later in this
course it's not far away in fact we are
going to move from one-dimensional
inequalities to two-dimensional
inequalities and then guess what
up or down really does matter and so I'm
going to encourage you to do what's
correct not just in this context but
also on that one that's why I do it on
the line okay
all right now how do we say all of this
the same thing but in this new fancy
notation okay here's the way I'm going
to call you back to some of our previous
things that we wrote do you remember
when we said if you're describing the
domain of object you can say X can take
on all real values remember that right
and we use this some funny symbol do
they don't remember what Greek letter it
was that's an epsilon thank you looks
like an e ya e for epsilon now the next
thing I would have written if I wanted
all the values was that funny-looking
capital R right remember that but I
don't want every single value everywhere
I only want the ones in this interval
right in between here and here so here's
the way I write it I'm gonna write two
little square brackets like so and talk
about those more in a second and then I
just included my two numbers my
endpoints one and three right the way I
would read this is X belongs to is part
of this set of numbers all of the
numbers between 1 & 3
the square brackets they are included
right so these boundaries are included
that's sort of parallel in the
inequality you know how we write that
less than or equal to sign so that's
when we have square brackets right yep
wait wait say that again like this these
two yeah yeah yeah absolutely yes so
literally everything I've got here on
this one line it all means the same
thing yep perfect exactly right so these
two numbers here are my beginning and my
end and they're correspond to this
beginning and this end right so these
literally all mean the same thing and
it's important for you to be able to
represent it any of these ways but also
interpret any of them to be able to see
this and then be able to draw this or
write this okay now I'm you know then
you told me these circles were filled
right they were closed circles so we
actually have a name for this based on
that word when we're talking about
interval notation we call this a closed
interval a closed interval because the
circles are closed they're filled we
include the boundaries right let's keep
on going I will speed up a teeny bit if
we wanted to not include the boundaries
so if I wrote something like negative 2
less than X less then 4 okay so this
does not include the boundaries we can
write this rather we can draw this on a
number line as well so as usual just
like putting the origin onto a Cartesian
plane I always like to have 0 in the
middle and I'm gonna put my boundaries
on so what would be the very subtle
difference on the number line with this
it's almost identical say it again oh
okay yes so definitely I've got a
different part of the number line
included the left-hand side but there's
another difference in how I draw it as
well as shown yeah very good I've got a
circle here don't I and it's um it's
hollow its unfilled it's it's open right
so
I'm going to close off this or color in
this interval here and because those
circles those endpoints are open has is
opposite to close I call this an open
interval okay now how do I then write
this in this new fancy interval notation
well you know how on your number line
it's a subtle difference whether the
circle is filled or not it's also a
subtle difference over here I'm gonna
say it whoops wrong color sorry I'm
gonna say X and I'm gonna say it belongs
to this set of numbers but instead of
using square brackets which include the
boundaries I'm just going to use the
regular old parentheses the ones we've
been using for almost everything and I'm
going to put in my two boundaries
negative two and four so when you see
these curly parenthesis that means the
boundaries are excluded like so okay